et on retrouve donc emmanuel dupuis pour
en parler un président je le rappelle la
destituer prospective et sécurité en
europe
emmanuel dupuis clairement quel est
l'objectif de cette visite déjà pour le
président afghan dire adieu sans doute
le président afghan a été mise sous
pression d'accepter des élections
législatives anticipées puisqu'il a été
élu en septembre 2019 souvenons nous que
quand ils oublient guen avait écrit une
lettre à ses comminatoire en disant que
c'était la seule solution pour que les
talibans reviennent à la table des
négociations ce qu'ils ont fait
nonobstant les attaques incessantes qui
se sont suivies
le président achats frannie rencontre le
président américain alors même qu'une
délégation américaine se rend en turquie
pour rencontrer leurs homologues turcs
on voit bien que les américains qui ont
accepté de partir sans condition et qui
ont engagé leur rapatriement de leurs
troupes déjà très engagée puisque votre
reportage mentionne qu avec que ce
rapatriement a commencé le 1er mai d'un
symbolique que le président donne altran
voulait utiliser comme la fin de la
présence américaine en afghanistan mais
ce déploiement est très très engagée
puisque près de 50% des 3500 américains
sont déjà partis d'afghanistan
donc on voit bien que les leviers de
l'afghanistan est en train de sombrer
dans une certitude de d'instabilité le
chef d'état major américain mc miley
dans une audition devant le congrès a
été encore plus incisif et peut-être
encore plus pessimiste que la
représentante spéciale d'abord à
l'alliance du secrétaire général des
nations unies 7 représente cette
diplomate américaine mentionnait que 51
des 4 119 districts étaient tombés le
chef d'état major américain est beaucoup
plus précis il évoque le chiffre de 80
districts et bien évidemment en
résonance ou en écho avec un rapport
d'un des services de renseignement
américains nommément l' agence de
renseignement du ministère de la défense
qui précise que au mieux le gouvernement
afghan résistera six mois
avant que les talibans reprennent le
pouvoir donc en gros après vingt ans de
présence américaine de 1400 militaires
américains tués près de 3 trillions de
dollars dépensés on revient à une
situation qui ressemble à la prise de
pouvoir des talibans en 1996
ça veut dire que c'est retour à la case
départ tout ça pour ça envoie l'armée
afghane et les ministres essaye de se
sont tous formés pour pour tenir alors
certes
washington a promis de continuer à
soutenir le gouvernement afghan une aide
diplomatique économique et humanitaire
mais mais c'est vrai que ça paraît vain
alors ça paris doute en vain que les
talibans ont une stratégie votre partage
le mentionne la prise de la ville
frontière avec le tadjikistan est
beaucoup plus que symbolique ali
stratégique
ça permet de bloquer ou de fortement
limité le rapatriement des matériels
militaires américains qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d' échappatoire soit par le
pakistan soit par l'ouzbékistan ne
soient pas détaillées qui ce temps il se
trouve qu'une déroute est désormais sous
le contrôle des insurgés est plus sous
le contrôle étatique
cela évidemment va un peu perturbé la
manière dont les américains vont se
redéployer
et puis évidemment il ya la stratégie
qui consiste à ne pas rentrer dans les
villes ou dans les principales villes ya
à peu près une trentaine précisément 34
métropole capitales provinciales
afghanes les talibans estiment qu'elles
n'ont pas besoin de rentrer dans ses
dents c'est dans ces villes
premièrement parce que c'est là que se
trouvent les principales garnisons
singulièrement une partie des troupes
étrangères
au delà des 3500 militaires américains
et 7000 de l'opération les au loudes
supporte donc l'opération otanienne les
talibans savent très bien qu'une fois
que les américains seront partis et que
dans la foulée les différents
contingents allemands italiens espagnols
auront également quitter le territoire
l'armée afghanes comme ça a été le cas
dans le poste frontière déchire cannes
comme ça a été mon seul et mettront pas
plus d'une heure pour quitter les postes
c est la durée qu'a duré entre
guillemets l'offensive des talibans
contre la ville frontière on comprend
que les talibans vous venez nous
l'expliqué sont très organisés
et ils rencontrent certains succès
certains plutôt acquis droite ont ce
succès par exemple en termes de
financement qui soutient logistiquement
les talibans évidemment c'est le
pakistan et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la pression jusqu'à présent n'a
pas été suffisamment forte vis-à-vis de
voisinage pakistanais si on de trouver
un avantage à la politique afghane du
président donald trump s'est évidemment
d'avoir mis davantage de pression que
ses prédécesseurs vis-à-vis du puissant
voisin
évidemment qu'ils partagent une
frontière mais évidemment qui est une
base arrière pour un certain nombre
d'heures d'insurgés il existe un
mouvement taliban au pakistan et bien
évidemment les talibans afghans trouvent
refuge armements et ont trouvé formation
dans le pays voisin
mais il n'ya pas que le pakistan il y a
aussi des intérêts étrangers dans ce
contexte où dans ce conflit votre
pointage mancienne un certain nombre de
milices qui sont en train de se créer
une bonne partie de ces milices sont
liées à des communautés de communes
était ouzbèke la communautés tadjikes la
communauté hazara donc déchi donc
traditionnellement plus proche de l'iran
on a le sentiment que malgré nonobstant
la présence forte près de cent cinquante
mille hommes au plus fort de
l'intervention militaire occidentale
près d'une soixantaine de pays
on a l'impression que l'afghanistan
redevienne le lieu de confrontation au
milieu d'un certain nombre de puissances
la russie la chine et les pays du
voisinage et non des moindres l'iran à
l'ouest et le pakistan à l'est
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis d'avoir
été notre invité
ce soir nous avoir donc apporter votre
analyse sur ces deux dossiers merci à
vous